はい。
冬、寒くなってきましたよね。
みなさんは僕の家もそうですけど
いろんな家では暖房をつかっています。暖房
もちろん、皆さんの家もそうだと思うん　ですけども、
寒くなってくると暖房器具を使います。
エアコン、ストーブ、こたつ、ヒーター
様々な暖房器具で部屋を暖めると思うんですけども、
そういうことです(適当)
私は気づいてしまった。
いろんな部屋を暖めることができるが、
そう、そう、トイレだけは暖めることができない！
そうだろ♡
普通の部屋は、ぜんぜん、暖めれるんですよ。
だが！！！トイレだけは暖められない。
いや、お金持ちの人はそうかもしれません。
でもね、一般的な家庭ではね、ないんすよ！
トイレに暖房器具などないんすよ！ないんすよ！そう！ない！！
ないんすよ！！暖房器具が！！
なので、我々はトイレに、
いや、トイレにいくまでの廊下も寒いな…
トイレって、なんか寒いんすよ！
僕の実家のトイレも寒いし、この家のトイレも寒い。
トイレ
…………
寒いんすよ。
今回はですね、何とかして暖かいトイレを作ろうと思いまして
まあ、難しいですよ。
寒いからエアコンを取り付けるわけにもいかないし
こたつも置けない、ストーブも置けない。。。
どーしよ―！！！
あ、答えはここにあった。
昔、大量のカイロで、お風呂場にサウナを作ったとおもうんですけども、
それのちょっと改良版で、
今回はこちらの貼るカイロ30個入りを準備しました。
12時間継続します。
トイレの中を全部貼るカイロで埋め尽くすことによって、
トイレの中が12時間、暖房状態になります。
こうすることによって、最近、僕の家には友達やら後輩がよく来るので
僕も含めて僕の家に来る後輩の皆さんが、
トイレを暖かく過ごせる。
いいじゃあ、ないですか。いいと思いますよ。
素晴らしい企画だ！
貼るカイロ1000個あるんですけども、
これを全部、これを、トイレの壁とか、床とかに全部貼って、
暖かいトイレ、暖かくトイレができるトイレを作っていこうと思います！
部屋をくまなく…
あっためようぜ。
では行こう！！（転倒）
♬ドラム♬
では、カイロ1000個貼っていきます！
はい!!!!い――――ち!!!!
まさき＞いーち
にーーーーーい!!!!
まさき＞にーーい
さーーーーん!!
まさき＞さーん
これを1000回やります。
10.
Ha---------(溜息)
まさき＞もう10だぜ！
そうだよ。
あと、100回すりゃ、いいんでしょ!?もういいよ。
50.
まさき＞50.
緊張するね、普通に。
え、ここもあったかくね!?
まさき＞あったかい♡
何でここあったかいの？
ここ、貼られてるから。内側に。
うわwwここ、あったかいんだけど。
え、凄いねこれww
では、
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ、あったけーーーーーーー
あったけーーーー!!!www
やばいね！
あったか!
ちょうどいい、温度だと、思われます。
じゃあ、僕は、トイレ、するんで。また
いや、普通に、こもってみたい、いや、こもってみたいんだよね。
こもってみます。
うわぁ。
やばいよ、これ、
てか、苦しいてか、シャンショオが薄い。
まさき＞大丈夫?
いや、サウナの時と同じみたい。ちょっと↓
まさき＞やばいじゃん。
あぁ。やばいかも。
まさき＞いや、大丈夫?
ちゃっと、待って。
やばいこれｗｗｗ
まさき＞はじめさん??
まさき＞大丈夫?はじめさん。
まさき＞大丈夫x2
まさき＞大丈夫?
やばい、、
まさき＞酸素、酸素
あっっっっ。
意識、飛んでた。
まさき＞うん
、、、やばいぞ。
カイロのせいで酸素がねぇ。この部屋に。
まさき＞うぁぁあん♡
まさきx2、どうした、
うわあ!!
じんた＞はじめさん、まさきさん！
じんた＞酸素、酸素です。はじめさん！
早く出よう。
じんた＞やばい。
え!?
まさき＞じんた？
じんた？
おい、大丈夫か？
おい!
じんた、大丈夫か!?
maji yabai!マジやばいよこれ。
まさき＞これ、もう、外でよう。
やばいな。
やばいやばい、まじ外でよう。
マジでやばいこれ。
まさき!?
おいx3！まさき!?
やばい!
あぁ!!
k
酸素が（苦）。。。。。
足りない。
よし、いこう。
早く出よう！お疲れお疲れ！（急）
早く出よう！ほんと死ぬ、ほんと死ぬ！